hahaha guten tag clap it up everyone for
a key by the sleep bandit and a very
good sorry I'm sorry sign was still
watching great welcome to a key bus trip
undead and undressed don't know about
this game
don't worry neither do i let's play I
actually have no idea what this game is
well well seems you finally come around
what a sexy ass voice lations are in
order you've officially passed the
compatibility exam and are now ready to
begin your life anew oh [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] is he doing
what kind of I've seen this in a hentai
before it I mean I've seen this isn't an
anime before an anime this is the
greatest game master we have a situation
what's wrong they forgot the dildos
there's an intruder in the building
right now Oh Jeff let's skin the Freak
did ma who [ __ ] umbrella [ __ ] came
out of nowhere
[Music]
[Applause]
well she just kick that guy's ass with
an umbrella okay finally go some action
there we go there we go [ __ ]
I slap you I slap you I slap you guys
slap you I slap you I slap you
this guy knows how to slap oh [ __ ] what
happened do I look alright this is the
greatest game of all time I've never
played a game this great in my whole
life I don't want to play anything else
ever again he think we lost them and
it's time to lose those clothes as well
if anime to share some of my blood with
you of course that's what we're doing
Jesus Christ let's just make out already
thank you thank you getting more best
game 10 out of 10
this is too cool this [ __ ] game this
game if this game was half as cool as my
sunglasses then this game wouldn't need
vampires it seems to have taken I
thought she said it seems to have
awakened and I thought she meant my
erection so if I remember cranky Barra
is like the nerdy district in Japan it's
really cool I remember me and Marcel
would just enter like a random shop and
there's this porn everywhere so we get
to walk around Akiba Hara oh my god it's
just like I'm here let's enter them one
of the porn shops dammit I can't oh god
I'm sorry
hey I'm sorry I love ice it's like [ __ ]
off
[Music]
[ __ ] off will ya [ __ ] off mate
[ __ ] get out this is awesome though I
don't know like as a European you go to
like a Asian country like Japan or just
like wow you're fascinated even by like
the tiniest things what the [ __ ] is that
guy carrying on his back what is that
what is juice you know what it's Japan
I'm not even gonna ask a camera at the
clubhouse
now let's investigate what the [ __ ] is
on that guy's back what what it what it
what I I know no I don't know where I'm
going oh okay all right
let's fight some people with umbrellas
how are you feeling just good in there
like a muscle man good I'm glad to hear
it well done your opponent's clothes
looked pretty scuffed up when you think
their durability is lower enough you can
try pulling them off
[Music]
yes yes what Japan you are genius
you are so smart I will unload all of
you [ __ ] [ __ ] you and your
[ __ ] yeah I will
[Music]
[Applause]
graduations okay I bet that's as much as
my stomach can handle um yeah I'd really
like this game it's really cool it seems
really fun check it out if you want you
if you like and dressing people this is
clearly the game for you if you enjoyed
this video please leave a like subscribe
to become a bro today and I'll see you
bros in the next video as always thanks
for watching stay awesome
[Music]